je comprends pas ces propos en fait vous
dites et
dans ce reportage en fait vous voulez
être avocate ouais mais vous voulez pas
enlever vos toiles du vous voulez quoi
et ben en fait madame travaux importants
voilà tout le monde qui fait de tout ce
qui se passe dans
les dom ont d'abord été interdite alors
qu'on vient de montrer que c'était
totalement du mensonge est une importe
quoi pouvait pas boucler dans le temps
qu'avocate bon là on n'est pas
représentants de justice les juges par
exemple deux fois porter le voile mais
l'avocat c'est une profession libérale
il n'avait cédé devant la cour un club a
plaidé la cgem et quézac quand on me
dira c'était mac et sur wii vous pouvez
pas déjà libéré l'avocate bien sûr ça on
passe ensuite pour m'aider je ne pouvais
pas plaidé mais vous n'êtes avocate bien
sûr j'ai eu chaud mais également la luge
à belfast est quelqu un interrogatoire
je me dois d'aider
la raison vous avez raison c'est
interdit c'est la loi persiste il ne
peut pas [ __ ] c'est ce qui a été dit
dans ses skis dit dans le reportage est
avocate
vous voulez plaidé devant la cour avec
votre voile ou pas j'aimerais j'aimerais
bien mais ça peut pas avoir un plein et
un voile
un centre bien sortir
les artistes investissements ça a fait
rire il
est ce que vous fait comprendre qu'en
fait aujourd'hui on est dans une période
où les rapports à l'islam sont
difficiles vous êtes les premiers je
pense à le savoir vous avez
qu'aujourd'hui il ya des lois qui
existent et je pense que si aujourd'hui
ce n'est interdite vous a contacté de
façon dévié c'est un fait représentative
de ce qu'est la société aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui on fait passer des lois
séparatiste on dit que c'est contre les
religions non ses lois ses parties cela
elle vise l'islam parce qu'un problème
aujourd'hui avec les musulmans en france
d'accord vous vient des problèmes
aujourd'hui
du tout puisqu'il ya la grosse majorité
des français qui considèrent que l'islam
est une menace il ya la république et
moi j'aimerais bien qu'on les laisse
parler déjà ces français doxique et
vanessa va parler de vous d'accord wynn
holmes est d'accord mais j'aimerais bien
terminer oui en disant que si vous êtes
humide dans un documentaire sur l'aspect
radicale de l'islam c'est qu'à une bonne
raison c'est qu'aujourd'hui les français
regardent d'un oeil à ces voix un peu ça
comme une menace l'islam aujourd'hui et
du coup à ce titre je pense que votre
voile même madame est un symbole de
radicalité et d'autant plus quand vous
avez des propos vous êtes là je vais
être avocate mais en même temps je veux
pas enlever mon vol donc je verrai bien
gérer ça avec mon voix est du coup assez
tout nous ce qu'on voit c'est plus que
vous essayer de gratter aussi de la
place c'est un peu nous ce qu'on voit
aujourd'hui c'est pas toi tu n'aura pas
servi sur le 10 ans justement je n'avais
pas de serge et aucun intérêt comme pour
les français c'est un signe en fait de
radicalité aux siestes mais voilà
l'impression que vous voulez arriver un
petit peu dans les tribunaux de plus en
plus et c'est en cela en fait que vous y
arriverez marine le pen qui dit il sont
là ils sont par jamais un fait tient
énormément de force et qui pensent comme
moi et on le veut